that's what people think it's like just
because I like it that doesn't give it
any value like as an artist if you like
it that's all of the value that's the
success comes when you say I like this
enough for other people to see it not
other people like it so it's successful
that doesn't mean anything because
that's other people liking it is out of
your control all that's in your control
is making the thing to the best of your
ability it's all an offering to God and
if you're making an offering to God
you're not thinking about oh what's the
budget or I hope I hope these this
segment of the audience is going to like
it we don't we don't think like that
it's a higher
vibration we're making the best we can
make to the best of our ability out of
love and devotion that's what it is and
there is no I'm changing it for someone
else because it can't be better than
this devotional act that we're doing